this mississippi singing trio is getting
a whole lot of praise from the judges on
america's got talent resulting in a
first time ever collective golden buzzer
yep we're feeling all the emotions it
all started with music act chapel heart
wows with their original song inspired
by the queen of country we've always
been country music fans and dolly is by
far our favorite
president
for president charles
chapel heart immediately wins over
judges simon cowell heidi klum howie
mandel and sofia vergara with their high
energy personalities and performance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well we feel like they're taking us to
the church of dolly the group song you
can have them jolene is an ode to her
iconic 1973 tune
[Music]
we think dolly would be proud and it's
no surprise the judges and crowd erupt
and give the group a standing ovation
and the feedback is unanimous chapel
heart has something special i love the
song i love the energy i love the look
your joy is infectious everything was
perfect the song the energy trust me if
i hadn't used my golden buzzer i would
give you a golden buzzer
but it gets even better after much
deliberation simon cowell pulls everyone
together to give the girl group a
surprise of a lifetime
five four three two one
yep chapel heart gets a first time ever
collective golden buzzer sending them
straight to the live shows
it's a special moment sophia previously
teased to e.t we have an extra golden
buzzer that we had last season though
and that was that is amazing because
sometimes we feel that there's it's not
fair that we don't have more of them
because everyone is getting so good of
course the judges have been generous
with the love in season 17.
[Music]
sophia sent the hypnotic lebanese dance
crew the mayas threw with a golden
buzzer and i want to be part of this
then there's simon cowell's pick 13 year
old sarah james who dazzled with her
impressive billy eilish cover
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and who could forget howie's choice
eleven-year-old singer maddie taylor
baez who shocked the judges with her
rendition of amazing grace
[Music]
her impressive vocals were enough to
grab everyone's attention and the
ultimate reward
[Applause]
and speaking of vocals heidi's golden
buzzer soulful opera singer marissa
bettos
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no doubt this year's competition is
turning out some serious contenders to
take home the one million dollar cash
prize
this year
i mean it is off the hook it's not
normal
[Music]
you